hi my name is Jeremy Walker welcome to
youtube developers live today we have
Jeff bo da Hye he's he's actually here
from stupeflix and they also produced
replay which is a mobile app which we're
going to talk a little bit about it's
all stupeflix so why don't you talk
through where stupeflix came from a
little bit of history of it Before we
jump in to any demos of course yeah it
all comes from Francois lagunas or CTO
who was the head of research at
dailymotion I'm sure you heard of that
service he was experimenting with GPU
cards trying to process videos faster
and what he found out is that we GPUs
you can actually render videos 100 times
faster than was possible at the time and
so we built the first-ever service to
render videos in the background in real
time at at scale we a service that still
exists today that developers use to
create videos and on top of that we saw
the need for people to express
themselves yeah video and still today
it's a pain if you want to edit you know
your weekend photos and videos into
something memorable and so we've been
passionate about resolving that through
a web app at first under the stupeflix
brand that had millions of users one of
the leading websites to create videos
online and now with replay the iphone
app that lets you create in seconds
beautiful video montage great and and he
started it in Paris right correct yes
that's we were seed came company so
Seedcamp is the equivalent of y
combinator in Europe we were part of the
first batch back in two thousand eight
and we're also part of the 500 startups
family so we're across both continents
great and actually before we jump into
demo because we're actually going to
show demos the mobile and the web app
but Before we jump into that I want you
to tell the story about stupeflix and
however likes to the harry potter
because i thought that was already
interesting open up and get as the US
co-founder what did you call
companies two-bit flicks at and it's a
recurring question it turns out it
actually comes from Harry Potter and
again Francois is a fan of harry potter
and stupefy is a spell that stops you in
all and that's really the effect that
the technology had to the people we
demoed it and so we kept that as a
company name for stupid flicks that's I
think that's great well well a little
bit let's jump into demos be people
people always love those so first we're
going to show you guys a video of the
mobile app which should be which we will
have just been released and then we'll
come back and we'll talk about the web
app excellent so replay for iphone let's
go amazing cameras always at hand we
take so many photos and videos by itself
each of these photos that's not say very
much but together they hold the sum of
our memories together these photos and
videos to other stories of our lives and
our adventures we believe video is the
most profound medium for self-expression
replay lets you make amazing videos and
celebrate the beauty in your life
what's mind-blowing about replay is how
easy an instance this experience is
in a speech second dozens of photos and
videos are analyzed filtered stabilized
cut and perfectly synced to the music
all the editing is done for you you just
need to choose a theme that sets the
right tone and tell your story the
iphone giving you does all the heavy
lifting replay renders because legally
in real time at 30 frames per second we
built a whole rendering engine on top of
iOS using opengl it's unique and that's
what it takes to produce this instant
experience replay is exclusive to iowa
and was designed for iOS 7 it espouses
beautifully the design philosophy of the
iOS 7 while showcasing the graphic
processing power of the latest iPhones
in particular we made sure we play fully
takes advantage of the 64-bit
architecture of the new a7 processors
even rewriting assembly code with a
30-percent performance game we were very
proud of replay a small team of GPU
programmers and motion graphic designers
push the boundaries of video creation
mobile replace technology is a unique
showcase of the graphic prowess of apple
new processors replays experience is an
invitation for anybody to feel empowered
to make their own beautiful videos and
becomes for
replay lets you make beautiful videos
you will be proud to share that's it
replay great that's that's a pretty cool
little app and I liked all the stuff you
could do so so hopefully that gave you a
good idea of replaying you'll go
download it now and try it out now let's
jump into stupeflix and see the web app
and then we'll kind of lead into the
last part of the conversation around the
api's so if you want to demo that for us
of course and by the way both of these
allow you to use they use the YouTube
API is to allow you to upload to YouTube
absolutely yeah all of our applications
use YouTube as a natural destinations
for the content that is being created by
users and developers right and the the
specific thing about replays that the
rendering happens on the phone and
that's really what's unique and as it
doesn't exist anymore and took us two
years to take the technology from
stupeflix and porting into this app but
the video creation experience starts
with with stupeflix and stupid flicks is
a web application there was one of the
launch partners of the YouTube create it
was a few years ago platform third-party
apps and so what it allows you to do is
to take photos and videos from wherever
they are it can be facebook instagram
flickr etc all from a computer webcam
and add them together very simply to
tell your story you can add text caption
text slides everything but the main
thing is that it's super easy to use and
you never have to think about video
editing all you have to worry about is
the story you want to tell and then you
click preview to see what it's going to
look like and when you do we render a
video is in the back in the background
in text ten seconds which is very unique
about this application and when you're
here it comes
and you guys sync with music and stuff
here as well right yes so all the
editing the transitions the music
matching syncing happens automatically
and selects a bunch of different themes
that will give a different-looking feel
but basically you have your video and
you're done and then it looks like this
and you can upload to YouTube 1-click
great so yeah if you use a mobile check
out the mobile app and definitely check
out the web app so you guys you talked a
little bit about your CTO figuring out
how to you know really take advantage of
GPUs to really help the process of
transcoding and all that great stuff so
my understanding is not only do you guys
have apps you also for people who are
more just interested in giving the
videos to you to handle and then just
getting them back you guys offer an API
yeah absolutely so if you have one video
to make you have the stupid hooks calm
website but then you if you have 10,000
or million videos make then there's our
API and that's really the first a
product that we launched back in 2009
it's been used it created 20 million
videos for small developers and big
brands like red bowl for instance right
now has amazing experience I can show
you where you connect your Instagram
account and we'll pull some photos and
features them as if you had a whole
gallery opening around your Instagram
photos Oh regal do now do a lot of the
stuff that we see in the apps is that
available through the API is like the
music synced to the images and the
videos and like adding all the text and
all that good stuff that's all available
absolutely and you know that's the
exciting thing about the API is it's the
first and still the only service that
lets you actually code videos you can
write using our XML video description
language how a video is going to be
edited and you can do simple things like
you know trimming a video adding a
bumper intro overlay things like this
adding text
but you can do pretty advanced stuff
like the the Red Bull example i
mentioned have a couple clients here
that can show you this is a real estate
property video service that makes videos
automatically great so so so for
professionals that like did this isn't
there their focus you just let them give
them a bunch of stuff and then they
figure they use your api's once i kind
of order it and then you take care of
all the rest and get them back a nice
video they can employ right and you have
the same level of granularity in the
design that you would if you were
actually designing your video with adobe
after effects except that it's all
programmatic and the rendering happens
super fast and you can make millions of
videos and so we handle scale so so yeah
this is this is quite amazing technology
and what people have made with it is
really really cool great well well why
do we switch gears and talk a little bit
about the developer side of the
assistance we're talking about apic so i
know for the the mobile app you guys
used you know objective-c what was your
main language for all the server side
stuff well python guys um so yeah GS
html5 python in the back end and one
thing that I think's interesting for me
for you guys is you actually started on
the YouTube API is very early yes so you
guys have transitioned from v1 to v2 to
v3 correct yeah we've seen it all and
yeah it's been an amazing right we've
probably uploaded about million videos
from our users on their YouTube channels
and so we've had volume and we've had
the history of building on top of those
so from that experience I guess do you
guys have any for people that are new
and starting on the new our new API
which is v 3 version 3 do you have any
like things you like to point out for
them to get started maybe lessons you've
learned along the way sure yeah going
from v2 to v3 isn't a big deal it's it's
much easier than the transition from v1
to v2 you expectations there is a better
means a smaller error rate which is
important for us because we do a lot of
those and so when there is an upload
failure then that that looks bad from
from from the users perspective and one
of the cool things that we can do now is
resumable upload so if there is a
network failure sometime during the
uploading of a video then we can resume
that video and have a successful
experience for the user so that's really
cool another cool thing that's maybe not
specific to v3 or obvious but that is
actually very exciting for developers is
the attribution a year ago if as a
developer you would have videos uploaded
to a channel user channel then the
attribution would not be clickable and
today there is actually a flow from
YouTube back to your application which
is very exciting it's still a small link
down there in the in the description but
it's really cool yeah and it's for
developers out there they're making apps
that are allowing you to upload YouTube
a lot of partners like you guys will
take advantage of the description area
too yes a produced by you know and then
i'll link back to your absolute and they
can take advantage of that great i was
going to ask you some features you like
that you kind of named off some so
that's great is there any uh any missing
things that you'd like to see in the API
that aren't there today just yes yes and
and and that's really my observation of
what our users want and on the web app
we see that maybe half to two-thirds of
the videos are uploaded to YouTube are
for professional purposes much more much
more than personal videos and so these
guys are very specific needs and they
want to be able to market themselves as
much as possible through their videos
and so anything that could allow us to
build into
the upload functionalities some of these
branding branding needs from our
customers would be great so I know there
is a watermark feature but we're not
able to to build too much on that
specifically on behalf of a user but
yeah annotations all these things that
that you see professionals using on
youtube com would love to be able to
give them access to via our applications
right so so for those out there we do
have a watermark API that allows you to
put a little water mark in the video but
it's across the whole channel with I you
guys are looking for video specific
watermarks which that's definitely an
interesting feature request we could
take taken and take back to the team the
other one is we do have for annotations
we do have standard annotations for the
in-video programming api but those are
knowing featuring videos right now on
your channel or the channel itself so we
are going to expand that out hopefully
so that we will but hopefully that'll
help you with your with your customers
as well oh yeah that would be amazing
for sure yeah great well I thanks again
for coming today and thanks for joining
us and again the developer team at
YouTube here is always hiring so if you
guys are interested in joining the
developer relations team check out
developer google com slash jobs and
apply there thanks again take care